one of the biggest controversies in
World sport right now involves the Saudi
Bank live golf tour which in the words
of star Rory mcilroy's ripped golf apart
it's lured a series of superstars with
Untold riches and taken a lot of
criticism for supposedly whitewashing
the image of the Saudi Arabian
government golfing Legend Greg Norman is
The Man Behind the live tour and he
joins Me Now Greg great to talk to you
yeah thank you pierce thanks for having
me on so look I'm heading up to the
Alfred Dunhill Lynx Championship which
is one of the biggest pro-ams as well as
the main tournament in the world I'm
going to be surrounded and maybe playing
with one of the top PGA players and I've
got to say as a golf fan who loves Golf
and loves watching top golfers this
split in the sport is quite
heartbreaking and I guess my first
question to you is how does this all
resolve itself do you think
well I think over a period of time it
will resolve itself peers there's no
question about it um look in a let's
just clarify this split I think the
split or this animosity has only come
from one side of The Ledger quite
honestly one thing we have really shown
case is that the golf is a Force for
good right and competition is really
fantastic for any part of any business
any sport even in your profession
competition is fantastic for you so what
we've done is just put another
competitive platform for the independent
contractors which is us which we've
always been I believe independent
contractors have a choice and have a
right to go somewhere else and play the
game golf appears the whole thing about
what we've done with live we built the
entire system from the ground up to work
within the ecosystems we tried to reach
out with the European tour we tried to
reach out with the PGA Tour we wanted to
integrate ourselves within their system
to show that what we have is additive to
the to the sport of golf and so we've
just decided that our product has stood
up the test of time in a very short
period of time in 12 rounds of golf the
players love it the fans love it so
we've just decided to go ahead and
launch and you know we've like I said
we've given the opportunity to work with
the PGA Tour to talk to the PGA Tour but
they made the decision not us when you
hear someone like Rory McIlroy he's one
of the top players in the world right
now without any question and a very you
know a passionate and eloquent defender
of the PGA Tour when you hear how
scathing he is about what you're doing
what is your what's your message to him
well my message is Rory you're an
independent contractor you have the
right to make your decision remember
Rory started on the European tour then
Rory decided to leave the European tour
to go play where where all the money is
where I went to play to the PGA Tour why
did we do that pierce we did that
because that was the only option we had
as players we had to go sign on to their
rules and regulations we couldn't even
negotiate their rules and regulations so
we had to do the only thing we could
possibly do is play the tour what we've
done now is give them options hey Rory
happy days do what he wants to do you
know if he's comfortable over there
doing that he's an independent
contractor he can if Rory wants to go to
the Middle East and get appearance money
to play in tournaments Happy Days go
play in those Rory that's your choice
don't begrudge the other players for
making the decision that is a rightful
decision under their independent
contract or rights to go do it it's just
a shame that people have taken this
stance when you if you look back over a
period of time they're pretty much done
the same thing themselves do you think
that it's about morality or money and
the reason I asked that is I actually
wrote a column for the New York Post
about what I thought was the hypocrisy
about a lot of the sports washing debate
in the sense that the Saudis already
have a Formula One Grand Prix they they
own a Premier League Football Club
Newcastle they stage all the big boxing
bats and that none of that gets anything
like the kind of
or program that you guys have had for
setting up a Saudi sponsored golf tour
and I don't understand what the
distinction is I don't also understand
how the PGA if they're being honest with
themselves could say that they
themselves never do business with
regimes which wouldn't hold up to much
human rights scrutiny so I see a
hypocrisy there what's your view about
that
look past you hit the nail on the head
hypocrisy the hypocrisy coming out of
this is so deafening it's ridiculous
um because you're right the PGA Tour has
title sponsors that have a great
relationship and working relationship
for a commercial opportunity with the
Saudi government with pis whatever it is
pif has done a lot of indirect and
direct investment in a multitude of
opportunities there's probably here in
this country one third of this country
are the benefactors of that so I don't
understand why it is that way sadly I
got an idea because we're the
monopolists I mean we're going in
challenging the monopolist which is a
PGA Tour it's been the one place to play
golf for the last 53 years all we've
done it is come in and shown another
opportunity another additive opportunity
now for the players to make their
decision oh my gosh I would have loved
to have that decision in my day when I
had the choice to go and play both tours
appears we're not asking our guys the
live guys just to play live and nowhere
else in the world we're asking our guys
we're giving them an opportunity you
play here you can go play anywhere else
in the world you want to go play we're
not holding restricted covenances on you
where you can't you don't have to get a
release you can go do whatever you want
to do and that's what I'm proud about
I've given these players who then live
the opportunity to grow their wealth and
give give them the opportunity to go
other places to play the argument
against what you're doing as you know is
that you're just throwing huge amounts
of cash at the top players many of whom
are taking it that the format of what
you do is not as good as the PGA because
you don't have a cut system there's no
kind of losing if you like there's just
equal you know different degrees of
winning and also that at the moment
you're not getting many people watching
this the streams aren't getting much
traction and that you need a network to
actually take this to the next level do
you think you're going to be able to
achieve that and have you got networks
you think you are going to rise above
the Sport washing debate to do what you
want to do
well 100 Pierce 100 look going back to
the money issue right we've been the
leader you take live out of the equation
the PGA Tour would never reacted the way
they've reacted by increasing their pip
increasing their 20 elevated events
giving more money to the players this is
what they should have been done in debt
during decades and decades ago there are
501c6 their Charter is to promote
professional tournament golfers right
promote professional tournament golfers
but here all of a sudden Liv comes along
then all of a sudden all this money pops
out about nowhere out of their Reserve
how do you think the players feel
that are either on the level of being
you know decades and decades in the game
of golf even me included saying why
didn't I have the right to play for this
money if you've had this in reserve all
this period of time for just all of a
sudden pop up out of nowhere because of
live
you've got to ask a lot of questions
about that and these are the part of the
things where you know from my
perspective what we're producing with
live we're a commercial entity we're
investing in New in uh new value in the
game of golf and Piers what is that new
value it's the Virgin space that's been
sitting there unidentified for years
which is the team franchise value and
the players love this opportunity they
have embraced it they have loved the
team spirit yes they play individual at
the same time talking about your format
but the players love the fact that they
can play individually and they play as a
team to see the camaraderie and the
locker room and the way these guys
interact week in week out it's 14 Ryder
cups every year going from 2023 onwards
only on the okay on the morality Point
I've seen a lot of your players some
handle it pretty well when they get
asked about this others have not handled
it so well some have been completely
buried like Phil Mickelson which I think
has been incredibly unfair actually and
I'm sad to see a legend of the game like
can be pilloried in the way that he has
but they're obviously legitimate
questions about the Saudi regime about
the murder of the journalists khashoggi
and so on you know even you when you've
been asked Greg about these things have
said things in by way of response which
have led to criticism you know are you
free because of your association with
the Saudi government in this way are you
free to be critical of their human
rights records and so on
look I mean here's what happened with
khashoggi's reprehensible but what we're
doing now is with golf in the game of
golf what we're doing is showing golf is
a Force for good across the world across
all platforms we're reaching down we're
reaching up we're creating a
foundational base for this pyramid of
opportunities going forward not just in
the men's game of golf but we're looking
at the pathways and opportunities we can
do from Collegiate players I mean David
Puig for example just termed
professional and joined he was a US
amateur guy he came up from those ranks
we are giving these guys the opportunity
through golf being the Force for good to
be able to give them this Pathway to
where they want to go so yeah look
there's that side of the Ledger there's
no question about it there's going to be
questions no question about it but we
are a commercial entity we're investing
into the game of golf we're growing the
game of golf and I'll say this peers
I've been away involved with the game of
golf for 45 years in that 45 years I
have never seen another entity willing
to step up to this to date and give us
22 billion dollars to invest into the
game of golf I think that is a just a
powerful Testament to the strength of
the game of golf number one and the the
opportunity as a as a commercial entity
to get a Roi out of the game of golf it
is it is beneficial to everybody and to
see what it's done on a global basis I'm
a golf Ambassador I have been in my
other company traveling around the world
building golf courses in different
places around the world third world
countries and to see what golf can do to
open up countries to open up Hospitality
education do whatever we need bring in
the third party investment all those
opportunities the game of golf delivers
you we're seeing it happening right now
but again you know coming back to my
position as a fan I love playing golf
I'm a ropey 16 handicapper but I love
the sport and everything about it what I
I really am struggling you only have to
give me eight aside
yeah exactly yeah
um no but and I've loved watching you
play over the years what I'm sad about
right now is I you know you look at the
major tournaments for example if your
live golfers are not allowed to get
ranking points and then they can't
qualify for the majors they cease to be
in my view proper Majors if you're going
to have half the world's best players
not able to compete they're not major
tournaments are they similarly the Ryder
Cup which I absolutely love you've
actually got a split there between
players on the PGA tour disagreeing with
each other about what to do with that
you've got Matt Fitzpatrick the US Open
Champion saying he thinks that the Live
players should be allowed to play you've
got Rory saying the opposite What's
Happening Here is tearing the very
fabric of the game in two and I'm just
again I come back to how how does this
somehow get reconciled if you were
predicting what you think is going to
happen here where will we be in a year
or two years time
I look I ultimately believe there will
be some merging of the the powers to be
to sitting down having conversation we
don't want it right now because we've
tried and uh going back to what you were
saying before we didn't create this
turmoil we just came in with another
opportunity for the ecosystem within the
ecosystem for the players for the fans
our Innovation and our evolution is
second to none it is changing the way
golf is viewed you imagine about the
viewers right in production since we
came out since February the September
the 4th in Boston that moment in time
that last hour of Television that you
may or may not have seen that was
exactly quintessential what liver's all
about you've you've got four or five
guys playing for the individual and
you've got three or four or five teams
playing for the the teams there was an
hour of Epic television there was shots
going left right in the center we people
the fans see you know 50 more golf shots
played on our format than anywhere else
so we didn't really start this big fight
we didn't create this animosity and with
the Mages quite honestly peers they
should be Switzerland right if I'm a
major I want to have the best of the
best in my field they're the four Super
Bowls they're the four fa cups they're
the four whatever you want to call them
that should always remain up there
Switzerland away from anybody for them
to be dragged into this Quagmire
yeah there's gonna be a lot of questions
to be needed to be asked about that but
they should be apart from that if you're
a broadcaster of any of the four majors
you should be saying to them we want the
Live players in there because 26 out of
the top 100 players right now today are
Live players ow gr they've got to be
again Switzerland because they're an
independent organization there's 22
other tour events in this world that get
ow gr points and I can tell you this 21
of 21 of those 22 are far inferior than
what the live tourism you know it
reminds me why are we being targeted
right I mean in a way it reminds me a
bit of what happened to my favorite
sport cricket with Kerry Packer who I
know you knew very well and when that
first all started he was getting a lot
of the heat that you're getting not for
the same kind of reason but he was
getting the same heat for destroying
what people felt was a tradition of the
game and of course we now have the IPL
which is a hugely lucrative and popular
series which really would never have
happened I don't think with that Kerry
Packer and his courage you yourself have
gone under unbelievable fire you know
you've been snubbed up at the open they
wouldn't let you go to the Champions
dinner which I thought was actually very
churlish as a great golfing Champion a
great sporting Champion how are you
dealing with that kind of vitriol the
kind of disenfranchisement from the
sport and the official bodies that you
that were once so welcomed by how are
you on a personal level dealing with
that
um look be honest with you peers at
times my heat shield gets a little bit
weak because I am a human being I've
done a lot for the game of golf I was
number one player in the world for six
years I've done things in the game of
golf I've promoted the game of golf I've
grown the game of golf globally I've
took a mission on myself as an
individual player to fly all around the
world I was the first guy to do an
exhibition match mainland China I was
one of the first guys to go into the
Middle East and do that and through my
golf and business as at the same time I
continued to do that so when they do
these
what happened in the RNA was a petty
cheap childish shot be honest with you
and if you can't Rise Above It All shame
on you because if you were under the
under pressure from other people
exerting pressure on you shame on you
for you not to sit down and have a
discussion and to understand what the
live business model is and to see how it
sits within the ecosystem shame on you
because in business and remember a
commercial entity in business you
understand what your Opera what your
opponent's got you understand what your
uh your competitors got unpack it all to
see if you can actually work together
within the system to make both entities
better for each other not try and
destroy us and we haven't tried to
destroy the PGA
worked very very closely to work with
them have you lost personal friends in
in the golf world as a result of all
this
a hundred percent I have yep but if they
look if they want to judge me on uh lack
of information and lack of what uh
what's out there but they're they're the
ones with the small mind right when you
know the facts
you understand the facts you understand
the delivery mechanism and the business
model peers let me say this
my c-suite are the best of the best in
the world of business
the economists lawyers uh marketing they
came from a diverse section of sport and
business right knock golf why are they
why do I have over a hundred of the best
of the best in the business because of
the business model and the business
model is showing through the product
they're showing through so I'm lucky to
have these magnificent people behind me
I'm lucky to have an investor willing to
invest into the game of golf like they
are investing golf is lucky to have this
but do you and some people say great so
what what people say they say do you
have any moral line about any of this at
all in the sense that I think some of
your players were asked at a press
conference well if Vladimir Putin wanted
to set up a golf tour would you allow
that to happen would you want to be
involved in that in other words is there
a moral line that Greg Norman wouldn't
cross
my moral line is I believe in the
product my moral line is I've been a big
storage composer of growing the game of
golf on a global basis my moral line is
golf is the Force for good so when you
have this opportunity and I've seen it
Pierce I've seen it Beyond live right
prior to live I've seen what I've done
in Vietnam I've seen what I've done in
Mexico through my other businesses
through Golf Course design it is so
resonatingly just powerful to see the
strength of what the game of golf can do
in different countries of Around the
World to Change the economy of things to
change the hospitality to change tourism
all these little ingredients that
actually golf is the benefactor of but
golf was the initial reason why you
could change these deals so I am so
proud to be in this role Piers I really
am because my whole life somebody asked
me a question the other day Greg do you
think this is going to affect your
legacy and I said you know what maybe my
legacy on the golf course is not my
legacy maybe my True Legacy is what
we're doing with live for the game of
golf and giving this opportunity to
Collegiate players to eventually to
women to the guys we have today to be a
true competitor to show that you are
additive to the system and our product
is speaking for itself is it true you
offer Tiger Woods a billion dollars and
he turned it down
mm-hmm
no that's no no there were discussion
this was preemie there were discussions
with him but we don't get into any
discussion about any of the players
contracts
and final question Greg I'm going to be
playing the the Saint Andrews old course
and King Barnes and Carnoustie in the
Alfred Dunhill links you've obviously
you know been very successful on these
courses in particular I had a bit of a
meltdown on the 17th the famous Road
Hole of the old course last year live on
Sky uh where I hit I think room 416 with
my t-shirt can you just give me a little
bit of advice with your old player hat
on the how I should play the Road Hole
huh
well next time you hit room 416 try and
put it through that window and go exit
the other window that tells me you're
hitting the golf ball hard and long so
but now listen I'm with you pierce I
love St Andrews it's one of my favorite
golf courses in the world if the road
holders has really hit every player has
ever played no matter your best in the
world or you're not
um and it's just you you're you're lucky
you're lucky to be involved with Johann
Rupert he's a he's a staunch supporter
of the game of golfer what he does there
in Scotland year in year out so go enjoy
yourself that's all you can do have fun
and and hopefully one day I'll be able
to play Saint Andrews with you I would
love that and I hope this all gets
reconciled and I hope golf gets together
because I think actually you can all
bring something to the party and I do
think the debate is laced with hypocrisy
and I've said that publicly and I I
believe it and it's not to say that I
agree with everything thank you for that
but I but I do think there's a lot of
hypocrisy about the argument and uh I
hope the golf is in the end the winner
and that everyone comes together and we
can all enjoy all the very best players
taking each other on again Greg Norman
thank you very much
thank you very much peers